heute spreche ich über sechs dinge die
ich an japan mag manche dinge mag ich
weil wir sie in deutschland auch haben
und manche dinge mag ich in japan weil
sie mir in deutschland fehlen
punkt eins öffentliche toiletten in
japan gibt es fast überall
öffentliche toiletten öffentlich heißt
dass jeder sie benutzen kann
es gibt in bahnhöfen öffentliche
toiletten in u bahnhöfen in parks in
einkaufszentren und das beste ist diese
toiletten sind immer sauber und immer
umsonst
in deutschland gibt es weniger
öffentliche zu lernen
in u bahn stationen gibt es keine
öffentlichen toiletten in bahnhöfen gibt
es öffentliche toiletten
aber sie kosten geld sie kosten zwischen
50 cent und 1 euro
und sie sind nicht immer sauber das
finde ich krass punkt 2 in japan gibt es
überall wasser umsonst umsonst heißt
kostenlos wenn ich in einem restaurant
bin dann bekomme ich immer kostenlos
wasser und sogar wenn ich nicht in einem
restaurant bin bekomme ich kostenlos
wasser in museen in parks in kaufhäusern
überall gibt es wasserspender und
überall ist das wasser und sonst in
deutschland ist gar nichts umsonst wenn
ich in einem restaurant wasser bestelle
dann bringen die kellner immer wasser
das ich bezahlen muss wenn ich extra
leitungswasser bestelle dann heißt das
dass ich was umsonst bekommen möchte
manchmal bekomme ich dann auch wasser
umsonst aber manchmal nicht das finde
ich etwas peinlich in deutschland punkt
3 ist die sicherheit in japan
japan ist eines der sichersten länder
der welt und das merkt man auch auf der
straße
es gibt keine menschen die einen
aggressiv ansprechen es gibt wenig
diebstahl und natürlich fühlt man sich
gut wenn man reist oder wenn man hier
lebt das vierte was ich ein jahr vom
markt ist die privatsphäre in japan
achten die menschen sehr auf ihre
privatsphäre und in deutschland ist uns
unsere privatsphäre auch sehr wichtig in
deutschland brauchen wir viel zeit für
uns selbst
wir respektieren individuelle
entscheidungen wir brauchen immer etwas
abstand zu anderen menschen und wir
verbringen weniger zeit in gruppen als
menschen in anderen ländern
und weil das in japan und in deutschland
ähnliches mag ich das in beiden ländern
punkt 5 ist die freundlichkeit der
menschen in japan sind die menschen
immer super höflich und super freundlich
das fehlt mir in deutschland oft wenn
man in japan menschen kommuniziert
bleiben sie fast immer freundlich und
höflich
das hat man in deutschland nicht immer
das liegt auch daran dass man in
deutschland andere prioritäten in der
kommunikation hat in deutschland ist zum
beispiel direktheit und ehrlichkeit sehr
wichtig ich würde sogar sagen
ehrlichkeit ist in deutschland noch
wichtiger als höflichkeit
das heißt wenn es mir nicht gut geht
oder ich mit etwas unzufrieden bin sage
ich das auch und das führt natürlich
manchmal dazu dass ich nicht immer
freundlich und höflich bin ich
persönlich habe das an mir auch schon
gemerkt ich schätze die freundlichkeit
und höflichkeit sei aber manchmal zeige
ich meine unzufriedenheit
gegenüber anderen menschen das mag ich
an mir nicht aber es ist auch etwas
typisch deutsch und ich bin daran
gewöhnt immer meine meinung und meine
emotionen zu zeigen daran muss sich
vielleicht noch arbeiten punkt 6 ist
kein trinkgeld das geld für den service
ist schon in der rechnung inbegriffen
und es ist nicht üblich in japan
trinkgeld zu geben
das finde ich persönlich sehr praktisch
wenn man in deutschland in einem
restaurant oder in einer bar ist dann
muss man immer rechnen
bin ich mit dem service zufrieden gebe
ich viel trinkgeld bin ich unzufrieden
gebe ich weniger trinkgeld habe ich
genug trinke gegeben oder habe ich zu
wenig trinkgeld gegeben sieht das
komisch aus gegenüber dem kellner oder
sieht es nicht komisch aus ich finde
dass in deutschland manchmal sehr
kompliziert und es macht die abrechnung
nach dem essen manchmal etwas länger als
nötig deshalb gefällt mir die japanische
lösung das war mein kurzes video über
dinge die ich an japan mag
natürlich ist das meine eigene meinung
und jetzt freue ich mich auf eure
meinung schreibt mir einen kommentar und
sagte mir was ihr einen japan mögt oder
zum beispiel an deutschland wir freuen
uns auf euren beitrag
außerdem könnt ihr sie german
unterstützen damit hälfte uns jede woche
easy german zu produzieren
werdet einfach ein patent und ihr könnt
easy german abonnieren und uns auf
facebook und auf instagram folgen damit
ihr seht wo wir gerade sind zum beispiel
in japan die links sind unten
bis bald und bis nächste woche